الى مشاهدينا نرحب بضيفنا في الاستوديو
الفنان احمد سيف اهلا بك يا احمد انا
بعتذر انا لفظت اسم الاغنيه غلط الدنيا
رضايه الدنيا رضايه نعم دنيا يلا دايما
تكون ان شاء الله طيب يا احمد تلحين عزف
كتابه غناء مهندس صوت طيب وين بتلاقي نفسك
اكثر من هيك بتتشتت يتشتت تركيزك بين كل
هذول هي طبعا بالنسبه لي يعني
المزيكا كاحمد سيف انا لما اعزف لاحمد سيف
بتكون مكمل لاداء الصوت
الهندسه الصوتيه
والعزف الموسيقي بالنسبه لي كله مترابط مع
بعض طبعا
اليوم جاي اليوم
خلينا نسمع اولا احمد ومن ثم نكمل لقائنا
ايش رايك اوكي تمام
نسمع ارجي الصباح يا ورود من كلمات سفيان
جنو بهديه الغنيه من هنا وبهديها للسودان
وهي طبعا الاغنيه تفاؤليه للوضع الحاصل في
السودان ان شاء الله ربنا يصلح الحال
[موسيقى]
ارجو الصباح يا ورود بكره الشمس
حيط
المال
هنور للمرحله الجايه
[موسيقى]
اريد الصباح يا ورود بكره الشميس
جاء حيط الما
النور
للمرحله الجايه
[موسيقى]
حزن
نا
بفرحه غنايه
[موسيقى]
الصباح
بدري
اصل الصباح
والوادي
تنتصريح والدنيا
رضى
والدنيا رضايا
والدنيا رضاي
[موسيقى]
ا دايما الدنيا رضايه احمد ولا الوضع يعني
اليوم في السودان هناك جانب مشرق منا من
انه السودانيين يستقبلون اخوانهم النازحين
من الخرطوم فبالتالي هذا وضع ايضا جانب
مضيء للشعب السوداني نعم جدا جدا نحن
تعودنا على اخواننا دائما يعني متعاونين
مع بعض في الغربه وفي
احنا في ود مدني لكن خليني اسالك بانه
اليوم الفنان السوداني كيف يرى الوضع وكيف
ينعكس ما هي رسالته
والله يعني احاول يعطي الاب اكيد اكيد
طبعا يعطي الامل
ويعني بالاللحان وبالغنى
النصوص يعني المريحه للفنان يعني وذكريات
السودان الحلوه طبعا
اغنيه لصباح العربيه لسه في طور التحضير
من كملها صحيح ترى ما كملها يعني انا قاعد
اقراها ما كملتها راح تكملها وتهديها
لصباح العربيه ان شاء الله الخطوه
المستقبليه بعد هذه الاغنيه بعد الدنيا
رضايه
والله في مشاريع
انا كنت شغال فيها عندي مشروع مع الفنان
حسين الصادق
ان شاء الله
الوضع يتصلح في السودان نقدر ننتج اغاني
اغنيه عاطفيه يعني ايوه اغاني عاطفيه ايوه
ان شاء الله احمد شكرا جزيلا لك مقاليد
الهواء
خلينا نختم بصوتك احنا بنقول بنودع
المشاهدين وبنتركهم معك يا احمد معنى
دقيقه تفضل
قلبي
وطفشت
نقشت فيني
غياب العصر الحجري
زول
القيتا انا
في حته بعيده
[موسيقى]
زول سلامه
كلام الريداب
زول
ا زولك كده لو
تابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات